[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the State of the Union
address is still scheduled to take place
next week but it's not clear where it
will be delivered the Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi has said the
president is not welcome in the house
latest on that just ahead but first
there was a brief moment a small window
at the beginning of this week when it
seemed possible that our media
establishment might look inward and
learn something useful about itself
humiliation as always is the best
teacher and they were definitely
humiliated in the space of just a few
days two separate high profile news
stories turned out to be utterly
fraudulent first BuzzFeed announced that
former Trump lawyer Michael Cohen had
been coached to commit perjury by the
president United States the cable news
caucus immediately erupted in glee
finally we got him until Robert Muller's
office weighed in to point out that the
story thrilling as it sounded wasn't
strictly speaking true so that was
embarrassing
and then just 24 hours later our entire
ruling class United as one to crush a
group of Catholic school boys from
Kentucky who would apparently behave
disrespectfully toward an American
Indian man here in Washington a short
video clip on social media appeared to
tell that story the only problem was
there were other much longer videos with
a very same event and they revealed a
very different truth the students from
Covington Catholic did not harass anyone
in fact they were the ones being
harassed
ouch various media luminaries swiftly
deleted their scolding tweets some even
apologized for them for getting it wrong
self awareness made a rare appearance in
the national press court but the moment
passed quickly it is always painful to
concede your mistakes especially the
mistakes you make because you've allowed
mindless stereotypes rather than facts
to shape your understanding of the world
nobody wants to admit that it's much
easier to blame others and so the media
did just that yesterday the Washington
Post ran a story that summed up the new
consensus on the Covington students here
it is quote a viral story spread the
mainstream media rushed to keep up the
Trump internet pounced
got it the real villains here are not
the journalists who pushed for innocent
kids to be expelled from school and
punched in the face the real bad guys
are the people who are offended by the
fake story
they're the ones who quote pounced
that's what bad people do in Washington
Post headlines they pounce
so having absolve themselves of any
wrongdoing and recast themselves as the
real victims here the media went back on
the offensive against the Covington
students one of those students a boy
called Nick salmon made the mistake of
going on NBC this morning and here's
what happened next do you feel from this
experience that you owe anybody an
apology
do you see your own fault we looked at
that video and thought about how it felt
from the others perspective in other
words there were a lot of you a handful
of the others do you think they might
have felt threatened by a bunch of young
men kind of beating their chests do you
think if you weren't wearing that hat
this might not have happened or it might
have been different or something
aggressive about standing there standing
your ground yeah there's something
aggressive about standing there failing
to move is a hostile act we can have
people standing still in public places
get a move on son that's what NBC is
telling us just kidding
NBC it's actually fine with people
standing around most people anyway go
ahead and make the case for loitering
laws and see what happens NBC will
attack you was a fascist before you
finish the sentence NBC this doesn't
think that people like Nick Sandman
should stand in place it's quote
aggressive George Orwell imagined a
world like this 70 years ago in 1984 for
the disfavored Orwell wrote the smallest
thing could give you away a nervous tic
an unconscious look of anxiety a habit
of muttering to yourself to wear an
improper expression on your face was
itself a punishable offense there was
even a word for it faced crime
Nick Sandman committed face crime on
Friday there was just something about
his face something aggressive and
sneering for that crime some of our
superiors don't believe that Nick Sam
Sandman ought to be allowed to speak in
public let MSNBC's Eddie Gowdy explain
there was this attempt to kind of give a
fuller account of the young man and I
think a lot of folks were asking the
question when why do we always do this
in these sorts of cases when white boys
are involved we give privilege to these
white kids he can sit down with Savannah
Guthrie and redeem himself but then
there all of these other folk who we
just presume you know who aren't so
innocent privileged that's the real
problem here Nick Sandman has too much
privilege so says the tenured Princeton
professor with the cable contract that
Professor by the way works nine months a
year for a guaranteed salary that puts
him in the top 2% of all wage earners in
this country his day job has so few
demands that he can spend most of his
time sitting around a TV studio wearing
makeup and yet he is still the victim of
Nick Sandman's privilege the Ivy League
professor has far less privileged than
Nick Sandman who is a Catholic school
student from one of the country's
poorest states way less privileged
doesn't even compare that's the case
they're making let's be honest this
entire conversation isn't really related
to what happened outside the Lincoln
Memorial last Friday the people who are
angriest at Nick Sandman and his
classmates don't actually care what
happened there they don't even know they
haven't watched the video they don't
plan to this is not an argument about
facts and evidence and truth it's an
argument about identity
the Kentucky students are being attacked
for who they are not for what they did
or didn't do the sooner the rest of us
understand that the sooner we will
understand what is at stake here
everything is at stake here most
specifically our ability collectively to
live at peace in a multi-ethnic society
there's no longer an overwhelming
majority group in this country it is a
diverse country as we're often told
there's nothing wrong with
that but it takes thoughtful leaders to
pull it off the presumption of equality
is a prerequisite for a diverse country
once people start believing that some
groups are inherently inferior to other
groups they have more privilege they
shouldn't be allowed to stand in public
there's something about their faces we
don't like when people start thinking
that the whole project falls apart
people start hating each other and not
hating each other for their opinions we
could fix that people's views evolve
over time political divisions can heal
and often do but fights over identity do
not they are different identity does not
change it cannot be moderated or
controlled its inherent were born that
way when we go to war over who we are it
is a permanent battle it is a disaster
that lasts for generations identity
politics will destroy this country
faster than a foreign invasion you
should know that as you listen to them
push it relentlessly as they
relentlessly do